british prime minister boris johnson is
under pressure as he heads into regional
elections
after a series of damaging leaks
multiple media organizations are
reporting that mr johnson said he would
rather see bodies piled high in their
thousands
and impose a third coronavirus lockdown
the prime minister denies the reports
and says his office is investigating the
source of the leaks
now this follows allegations of
corruption made by his former chief
advisor who claims mr johnson asked
conservative party donors to pay for the
refurbishment
at his official residence
dw correspondent burgett mass in london
can talk us through this downing street
drama welcome berget where to begin
well quite some extraordinary
developments fell over the last
weeks and days when one of the prime
minister's most trusted advisors
dominic cummings practically the
mastermind behind his
leave strategy the brexit strategy that
was ultimately
responsible for boris johnson becoming
prime minister
so really one of his closest aides or
his closer day is now
turning against the prime minister and
saying
when it comes to the recent
refurbishment of
the downing street flat where boris
johnson lives with his fiancee
that the prime minister acted possibly
illegally and
unethically because the allegation is
that
boris johnson didn't pay for the
refurbishment himself but
that somehow through the conservative
party
money from conservative party donors was
channeled into the refurbishment now
downing street are saying
that boris johnson is paying all the
money
back but there is definitely an
allegation that something has been going
on that is not
transparent and this is something that
the labour opposition party
are obviously uh feeding on and they are
saying that
if there was any such money being
donated the prime minister
then that has to be made transparent
and of course the other comment about
the bodies piling up high in connection
with coronavirus
that also doesn't go down well at the
moment with the british public as well
may i say
so is this likely to have any
consequences for mr johnson
well it doesn't look good because at the
next and next and the next week we are
having
our local elections scottish elections
for the scottish parliament
so it does uh give the conservative
party quite
a lot of headache at the moment and they
will see if if their poles are dropping
as a result of this
i think it's the sort of drip drip of
allegations of of
sleaze because the refurbishment issue
of the flat is not the only
um point that came up there were other
allegations that business people like
for example uh sir james dyson the
businessman had
access to uh boris johnson and private
messages and that boris johnson
promised to fix a tax issue that the
businessmen were facing
also lobbying by david cameron the
former prime minister on behalf of a
financial
company lobbying with the government and
so there are quite a few allegations
that are beginning
to the the people are beginning to
notice it
uh but i think the the most worrying one
for the brit you know in the eyes of the
british public i would think
is there are the remarks the alleged
remarks of boris johnson when it comes
to the victims of the coronavirus crisis
um allegedly a very flippant remark that
he would rather see more bodies pile up
than go into another lockdown
i think this remark is being seen by by
people
definitely as very inappropriate if it
was true
bernie madison london thank you